[Music]  these are pounded potatoes  and yes  they stretch  but not just any potato can make this  dish to find these potatoes you have to  go to yunnan china  [Music]  yang learned to cook classic yunnan  dishes when he was 16 years old  [Music]  in 2010 yang brought yunnan cuisine to  beijing  [Music]  the secret ingredient to this dish is a  very special kind of small potato that  grows in yunnan  unlike the starchy yukon gold spuds that  are used in classic mashed potato dishes  the yunnan potatoes are waxy  and that's what gives this dish its eye  appealing stretch  your  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  sure  [Music]  often called grandma's mashed potatoes  in yunnan province yang likes to enjoy  this dish at home  [Music]  [Music]  you